- [Instructor] In this
video I'm going to assume
that you already know a few things
and we've covered this.
We've proved this in other videos
that sine of x plus y is
equal to sine of x cosine y
plus and then you swap
the cosines and the sines,
cosine of x sine y,
and then cosine of x plus y
is equal to cosine x cosine y
minus sine x sin y.
Once again, we've proven
this in this in other videos
and then there's some other
properties we know of cosine
and sine that we have
looked at another video's.
Cosine of -x is equal to cosine of x
and that sine of negative
x is equal to -sine of x.
And that of course,
the tangent of something is defined
as a sine over cosine of that something.
Now with that out of the way,
I wanna come up with a formula
for tangent of x plus y expressed just
in terms of tangent of x and tangent of y.
You can view it as the antilog
for what we did up here
for sine and cosine.
Well, the immediate thing
that you might recognize
is that tangent of x plus
y based on the definition
of tangent is the same
thing as sine of x plus y
over cosine of x plus y.
And what's that going to be equal to?
Well, we know that sine of x plus y
can be expressed this way.
So let me write that down.
So that's going to be sine of x cosine y
plus cosine of x sine of y.
And then, and actually,
so that we can save a
little bit of writing,
I'm gonna awkwardly write,
make the line down here,
because we're gonna put
something here in a second,
but I think you'll get the idea.
So there's going to be that
over cosine of x plus y
which is this expression when
you just express it in terms
of cosines of x and
cosines of y and sines of x
and sines of y.
So let me write it here.
So you're gonna have cosine
of x cosine y minus sine of x,
and then sine y.
Now we wanna express
everything in terms of tangents
of xs and ys.
And so it might make sense here to say,
all right, well, we know
tangent is sine over cosine.
So what if we were to
divide both the numerator
and the denominator by some
expression that can start
to make the numerator
and denominator express
in terms of tangents.
And I will cut a little
bit to the chase here.
So in the numerator,
what I can do is,
and I'm gonna do this
just in the numerator,
and then I'm gonna do it
in the denominator as well.
I'm gonna divide the numerator
by cosine of x cosine y.
And of course, I can't
just divide the numerator
by cosine of x cosine of y
that would change the value of the,
this rational expression.
I have to do that to
the denominator as well.
So I know this is a very
complex looking fraction here
but it's going to simplify in a second.
So I'm also going to
divide the denominator
by cosine of x cosine of y.
And now let's see if we can simplify this
in certain ways.
In the numerator, we can see
that this cosine y cancels
with this cosine y.
And so that first term becomes slightly
in another color here.
So this sine of x over cosine of x.
And so the numerator,
I can say this is going
to be equal to sine of x
over cosine of x is tangent of x.
And then the second term here,
we can see that this cosine of x cancels
with this cosine of x .
So we're left with sine
of y over cosine of y,
which is of course,
tangent of y.
So plus tangent of y
and then all of that is going to be over,
now we can look at the denominator.
So this first term here,
we can see the cosine of x
cancels with the cosine of x
and the cosine of y cancels
out with the cosine of y.
So you could view this first
term here when you divide
by this cosine of x cosine y,
it just becomes one
and then we're going to have the minus.
And now this second term is interesting.
We have sine of x over cosine of x,
sine of y over cosine of y.
So sine of x over cosine of x
that over there is tangent of x,
and then sine of y over
cosine of y its tangent of y.
So this is going to be tangent
of x times tangent of y.
And just like that,
we have come up with an expression
for tangent of x plus y that just deals
with tangent of xs and tangent of ys.
Now the next question you might say,
well, all right, that's
great for tangent of x plus y
but what about tangent of x minus y?
Well, here we just have
to recognize a little bit
of what we've seen before.
Let me write it over here.
Tangent of -x is equal to sine of -x
over cosine of negative x
and what's that going to be equal to?
And I know I'm running out of space.
This is going to be equal to
sine of -x is the same thing
as -sine of x, -sine of x,
and then cosine of -x is just cosine of x.
Well, this is just the
negative of the tangent of x.
So this is negative tangent of x.
And the reason why that is useful
is I can rewrite this as being,
write here.
This is the same thing
as tangent of x plus -y.
So everywhere we saw a y here,
we can replace it with a -y.
So this is going to be
equal to tangent of x
plus the tangent of -y,
all of that over 1 minus the tangent of x
times the tangent of -y.
Well, we know the tangent of -y
is the same thing as the
negative tangent of y.
And we know that over here as well.
So this could just be,
we could write the tangent of y here,
and then the negative would
turn this into a plus.
And so just to write everything neatly,
we know that also the tangent of x minus y
can be rewritten as tangent
of x minus tangent of y
all of that over 1 plus
tangent of x and tangent of y.